I have a lot of new followers out there
so I feel like I just need to say this out loud
my number one goal is to post as much pro choice feminist content as I can right
full stop
but second little just just for giggles goal is
I feel like if I pushed the right buttons at the right time
I could get on Fox News
the feminist lawyer
I post pro choice pro Taylor Swift
anti Trump pro Chapel Road content on TikTok
I am married but I don't have children
even though I'm 32
I make more money than my husband does
yeah
they would hate me first
like 30,000 followers if I do get on Fox News the feminist lawyer eventually
like they're just mad at me or making fun of me or something
we need to throw the biggest rager of all time
Taylor Swift says if you fail the plan
you plan to fail so I am planning to get on Fox News